[Musica]
siamo nella pineta di Ravenna
c'è un grande regista Michelangelo
Antonioni che sta girando uno dei suoi
capolavori Deserto rosso
e immagina una scena finale in cui la
protagonista Monica Vitti cammina
spaesata nel mezzo di una lunga distesa
di pini marittimi
ma non li Immagina del Verde che li
contraddistingue li vuole Bianchi
per fare questo è necessario
dipingerli così ingaggia una squadra di
operai che per tre giorni e tre notti
dipingono ininterrottamente Questi
alberi solo da un lato
alberi enormi alti anche 40 metri
gli operai salgono su scale altissime
che sembrano Instabili sono sporchi di
vernice dalla testa ai piedi
Antonioni tiene da sempre un diario in
cui scrive i suoi pensieri e i suoi
dubbi e in questo caso scrive i dubbi
che lo attanagliano rispetto alla
possibilità di riuscita di questa scena
nello specifico teme l'arrivo della
Brina O ancora peggio l'arrivo del sole
dopo tanti giorni di grigio il sole
renderebbe impossibile realizzare le
riprese
è mattina presto il lavoro è finito
Gli operai sono esausti
L'attrezzatura è ai minimi termini
ed è arrivato il sole
Antonioni scrive nel suo diario queste
parole
tutto quello che posso che devo dire con
la morte nel cuore al mio direttore di
produzione ora che è mattina presto che
è arrivato un bel sole e che non è
possibile girare è che rinuncio alla
scena niente Bosco bianco nel film
Questo è il bosco così come l'aveva
immaginato Antonioni
Ma questo Bosco non esiste
Non lo troverete da nessuna parte questa
foto è un'illusione è una messa in scena
basata sull'idea di Antonioni
gli alberi non sono gli altissimi pieni
marittimi della Pineta di Ravenna
ma sono miniature alte 10 cm
la nebbia è stata ottenuta con una
macchina del fumo
E l'immagine è stata post prodotta
digitalmente per ottenere l'effetto di
grandiosità del bosco
Questa foto è un'illusione
adesso ci spostiamo a curon Venosta
un piccolo paese in provincia di Bolzano
in cui il 23 luglio
1950 le case vengono minate per essere
demolite
solo il campanile resiste e si decide di
lasciarlo lì dov'è
gli abitanti si trasferiscono nel paese
a fianco l'acqua alla cala valle e
all'improvviso Il Campanile spunta dalle
acque di un lago che prima non c'era
quando lo specchio d'acqua è ghiacciato
è possibile raggiungere a piedi Il
Campanile Infatti questa foto è reale
se curon Venosta è così famosa a livello
turistico lo È proprio grazie al
sacrificio della curon vecchia
e grazie alla resistenza di quel
campanile che ancora oggi è fonte di
suggestioni e leggende
è uno dei tanti luoghi italiani così
insoliti e surreali da sembrare finto Ma
è un paese reale
e il suo aspetto fiabesco può essere
ingannevole al punto tale che c'è ancora
qualcuno che sente il rintocco di quelle
campane
c'è un altro paese
che già c'è sul fondo di un lago sotto
80 metri d'acqua a causa di un impianto
idrico ed è considerato la piccola
Atlantide italiana
si chiama fabbriche di careggine si
trova nel lago di Vagli in Toscana
abitato fino al
1941 anno in cui viene fatto sfollare e
di nuovo l'acqua allaga la valle il
piccolo paese di pietra improvvisamente
scompare
la diga però ha bisogno di manutenzione
così per quattro volte l'ultima nel 1994
il lago viene svuotato e il paese
riemerge Ogni volta sempre più incolore
sempre più diroccato
si racconta che in occasione dell'ultimo
svuotamento la gente arrivasse da tutta
Italia intasando la statale per
Chilometri e chilometri per vedere il
paese riemerso
ho collezionato
immagini di persone che sono state a
visitarlo che posano fiere un giorno
d'estate con alle spalle fabbriche di
careggine che sembra fatto di cartone
da quando ho scoperto l'esistenza di
questa curiosa storia Ho aspettato
invano un ulteriore svuotamento
ogni anno annunciato da giornali
nazionali dal siti web ogni anno
smentito come fake news
perché la diga non ha più bisogno di
manutenzione e quindi fabbriche di
careggine non sarà mai più visibile
rimane muto sotto tonnellate d'acqua
Allora immagino un palombaro
che si immerge nelle profondità del lago
arriva vicino alle case a una luce che
gli permette di vederle addirittura di
fotografarle
Questa foto è un'illusione
basandomi sulle immagini scattate dai
visitatori che sono andati nei vari
svuotamenti Ho ricostruito le 31 case e
la chiesa che compongono il paese
poi li ho immersi in un grande acquario
sporcando l'acqua con della melma per
renderla torbida
e infine ho cercato la giusta
prospettiva e la giusta distanza per
scattare foto realistiche verosimili
quindi di nuovo
una messa in scena una finzione
un luogo che sarebbe irraggiungibile
fotografato in altro modo
un'ultima insolita storia italiana
e la storia del signor annunzio
lagomarsini costruttore edile senza
titoli di studio che una volta in
pensione decide di dedicarsi al suo
sogno più grande
costruire una casa volante
di costruzioni bizzarre ne aveva
realizzate tante la più famosa è un
robot con le sue stesse sembianze
ma il suo sogno è una villetta
indipendente in grado di sollevarsi da
terra e permettere quindi di vedere il
Sole dalla posizione in cui si trova nel
paese di Castelnuovo Magra in provincia
di La Spezia
Inoltre vorrebbe una casa che ruota su
se stessa di 360 gradi cioè indipendente
dai punti cardinali perché pensa a
quanto sarebbe felice la moglie Emilia
se potesse avere sempre il sole nella
finestra del salotto
quella che ha in mente è una casa
impossibile utopica
irrealizzabile
ma a Nunzio ce la fa
la casa esiste veramente
per sette anni usando materiali di
scarto e rottami presi dai cantieri nei
quali lavora
si dedica alla costruzione di questo
capolavoro di ingegneria che grazie ad
un sistema di leve e cilindri alla fine
funziona
la casa Si solleva da terra di 20 metri
e quindi può vedere il mare
ruota su se stessa di 360 gradi e scorre
su dei binari che annunzio ha costruito
in giardino
per 13 anni Lui è la moglie vivono
felici in questo luogo
accogliendo visitatori
studiosi curiosi addirittura persone che
gli chiedono il brevetto perché è una
casa antisismica ma lui risponde che non
ce l'ha l'ha fatto a mente
Poi un giorno succede qualcosa di
inaspettato e spaventoso gli ingranaggi
si rompono e la casa si rovescia sul
lato
Emilia mi racconta della difficoltà di
rimettere tutti in sesto
ma con grande nostalgia mi racconta
anche di quanto fosse felice in quegli
anni in cui si svegliava la mattina e
non sapeva In che posizione fosse la
casa rispetto al Sole
oggi la casa
giace in posizione di riposo una specie
di gigante
addormentato e arrugginito che
testimonia la volontà di un uomo
semplice e geniale
per me è stato veramente un grande onore
riuscire a fotografarla
quello che voglio trasmettervi oggi è la
consapevolezza che non vi sia nessuna
differenza fra l'immagine di un luogo
reale e l'immagine di un luogo
ricostruito
Per me ha lo stesso valore viaggiare in
giro per l'Italia alla ricerca di
qualcosa di sconosciuto che vale la pena
rivelare
o la ricostruzione di un luogo che
diversamente non sarebbe raggiungibile
Perché la fotografia è Innanzitutto
immaginazione
il mio obiettivo è cercare di forzare al
massimo i limiti di ciò che può essere
rappresentato fotograficamente
quindi non pensate alla manipolazione
fotografica come al semplice fotoritocco
che viene usato per esempio sui social
per avere più follower
la finzione è connaturata alla
fotografia
addirittura si potrebbe dire che la
finzione in fotografia nasca con la
nascita della fotografia a partire dal
E questo perché la fotografia è uno
strumento di rappresentazione della
realtà ma la realtà è interpretabile
sempre e comunque
quindi pensate alla fotografia come a un
documento ma pensatela anche come ad una
forma di invenzione
pensatela come realtà ma anche come
spettacolare illusione
pensatela cioè come ad uno strumento
formidabile per rendere visibili i
nostri sogni
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]